political correctness continues to run
amok in our institutions so sage steele
is a really really talented broadcaster
over at espn and she does the the noon
sports center she's been doing
sportscenter at
at espn for years she happens to be a
biracial woman and she was doing a
podcast with jay cutler
and she made some controversial comments
now in the past she's been pretty openly
somewhat conservative sage has so the
the notion that sage steel was ever
really hiding the ball on her politics
is untrue and she's gotten blowback
pretty publicly from people at espn
about it now remember espn has become
msnbc with footballs esp
espn
spent years broadcasting whatever
idiotic political statements lebron
james wanted to make and then treating
them as though they were some sort of
moses on the mountain moment
anything anything dumb and left that
athletes say is projected into the
stratosphere by espn into anchors spent
four years making overtly political
comments about donald trump for example
to very little blowback unless they said
something so extraordinarily outrageous
that it drew like intense fire pretty
much every day was just dominated by
lies about
policing in the united states or about
systemic racism in the united states
and the espn went woke a long time ago
southern sports illustrated like the
entire sort of institutional sports
media is way to the left of virtually
all media maybe including political
media sage steel is an exception to that
right she's she's tweeted some things
that tend toward the conservative
and while she was on with jay cutler she
made a couple of comments she made one
comment about barack obama she was asked
by jay cutler about barack obama on a
census form saying that he was black as
opposed to biracial which he is right
barack obama is biracial his mom was
white and his dad was black sage steel
is also biracial and her dad is black
and her mom is white
and uh and here is uh here's what sage
steele had to say
and and she's like well what happens
when you uh when you fill out your
census i'm like well i don't know when
the last time i filled out my sense this
was but
if they make you choose a race yeah
she's like we're gonna put it i go walt
both she's like well you can't he goes
well what if barack obama chose black
and he's biracial i'm like well
congratulations to the president that's
his thing i think that's fascinating
considering considering
his black dad was nowhere to be found
but his white mom and grandma raised him
but hey you do you i'm gonna do me
okay so how dare she point out the
reality which is that
barack obama
you know characterizes himself as purely
black as opposed to biracial and she
literally says in that clip you can do
what you want right that's fine but it's
interesting how he characterizes himself
one way as opposed to another okay fine
like that that is a fairly inoffensive
comment when i say fairly i mean like
completely there's nothing offensive
about that right for her to say that she
who has the same racial status as barack
obama chooses to write mixed race on her
forms and barack obama does not is sort
of culturally interesting that's true
that is kind of a culturally interesting
interesting thing and it demonstrates
how our society tends to box people in
to single race thinking as opposed to
the reality which is that a huge number
of americans in the united states are
mixed race and that continues to grow
year on year
there's nothing particularly
controversial about that
and then she had this to say about
vaccine mandate so espn disney they put
down these vaccine mandates like a lot
of other major companies in the united
states sage steel is very critical of
that here's what you had to say
i respect everyone's decision i really
do but to mandate it is um
sick and it's scary so i get it to an
extent that i think the mandate is what
i really have an issue with and and i
i i don't know i don't know what comes
next
um
but i do know for me personally
i feel
i feel like defeated
okay and uh espn decided that they were
going to suspend her over this so they
issued a statement on tuesday saying
that steel would not return to the
network for a week foregoing her noon
spot on sportscenter and has been
removed as host of the 2021 espnw women
and sports summit taking place october
18th through the 20th
so um that's interesting they said at
espn we embrace different points of view
dialogue and discussion that makes this
place great
that said that said
always that said but
we expect that those points of view be
expressed respectfully and amen are
consistent with our values and in line
with our internal policies um i don't
see anything disrespectful about what
she said she was giving her opinion on
vaccine mandates it seems much more
disrespectful that you are forcing her
to get a vaccine to continue working at
espn and forcing people to continue like
that's what's more disrespectful a
person saying you will be fired unless
you take this vaccine that you have
questions about or the person saying i
think that's sick that you're doing that
which one is more disrespectful
seriously now listen espn's a private
company they can do what they want
with that said
would they have done this had the
situation been reversed and had the
person who was speaking been
hypocritical of president trump or been
hyper sycophantic toward barack obama
which espn was for literally all the
years that barack obama was president i
have serious doubts about that
the reality is that the heads of espn
are all to the left espn is attempting
to cater to a particular crowd that
crowd tends to to be toward the left
demographically speaking and so sage
steele has to pay the price for that she
put out a statement saying i know my
recent comments created controversy for
the company and i apologize we're in the
midst of an extremely challenging time
that impacts all of us it's more
critical than ever that we communicate
constructively and thoughtfully
so that is um
you know she's i i fail to see what she
says here that is fireable
like truly i don't understand what she
says here that is fireable or
suspendable that did not stop espn from
suspending her until apparently further
notice
i think there's a pretty good shot that
espn ends up canning her at the end of
this and i think the reason for that is
because yeah by the way i think the real
reason for that is espn is trying to cut
salary because they've been losing
viewers hand over fist and i'm sure that
stage steel has been working there for
quite a while makes good money over
there and they're probably just going to
find some excuse to canter because this
is what espn does
but again it is just indicative of how
stupid our culture is that if you go on
air and you're a biracial woman you say
something people don't like about barack
obama you might lose your job over it
or if you say that you don't like vax
mandates you might lose your job over
that
meanwhile that's not the only
politically correct attempted
cancellation of the day
so dave chappelle
has a brand new special on netflix and
he sort of alternates his specials he
does ones that are kind of woke and then
highly praised because they're not as
funny but they're woke by the by the
rotten tomatoes crowd and then he does
ones that are actually funny but
politically incorrect so he uh makes
some comments in his new netflix special
about the the phenomenon of turfs
trans-exclusionary radical feminists as
they are called by the trans community
meaning women who say that biological
women exist here is uh dave chappelle
defending jk rowling
i'm team turf
[Applause]
i agree
i agree man
gender is a fact you have to look at it
from a woman's perspective
look at it like this caitlyn jenner whom
i've met wonderful person
caitlyn jenner
was voted
woman of the year
her first year as a woman ain't that
something
okay for this sort of stuff glad is now
lambasting dave chappelle and they're
calling for dave chappelle to be removed
from netflix
glad said dave chappelle's brand has
become synonymous with ridiculing trans
people and other marginalized
communities negative reviews and viewers
loudly condemning his latest special is
a message to the industry audiences
don't support platforming anti-lgbtq
diatribes we agree amazing how the
people who are very much in favor of
expanding every quote unquote right to
encompass pretty much every activity do
not include among those rights speaking
what you think about things then you
ought to be de-platformed so
amazingly beautiful stuff here from our
sensorius left
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed